Ladies and gentlemen, this is day one of retirement and I am miserable.
I don't think I can remember a time where I was more bored out of my mind.
I don't know what you're supposed to do in retirement,
but I'm pretty sure this is not it. See, I looked it up on Google.
That was my first mistake. Quite frankly,
I think they're about to get shut down by the FTC or monopoly laws.
That's what I get.
It says retire on a cruise ship with less than a million dollars.
And obviously I'm broke. And I said, Oh, cruise ships sound kind of nice.
This time of year, nothing really happened to affect them, right? I mean,
some people say the cruise ships are very nice to be on and those,
some people are complete idiots. Guys.
I'm here to share with you some of my footage and it's miserable.
As you can see almost no one's here. You know what it is?
Cruise ships are a glorified hotel. That's what it is. That's all it is.
They have bad food, but it's free. They have a pooled at the same tin drunk.
People are always in and they have a room that smells like that weird
combination of human waste and Clorox. And that's about it, guys.
That's really about it. It's all really cruises have to offer for you. Actually,
I did think of a difference. You can leave a best Western.
You're not going to leave your carnival.
And then the cruise ship just has rooms like this,
which I don't know what the hell this is supposed to be.
Is this the weird room where Epstein sacrificed the young boys? This is strange,
but probably the worst part of all of this is you can't get a decent cup of
coffee, guys. This copy is so weak. So old. I had to ask, you know,
what type of coffee is it? Who, who makes this kind of coffee?
They show me this guys. It's Joe Biden's coffee. I mean, no wonder it's weak.
Right? And you know,
another problem is it's been like 24 hours since I've called someone out on
social media. And, um, you know,
getting the little bit of this shakes. I thought this would be easier to kick.
As I honestly think cruises are just a total waste of time.
And I think the rest of the world is like realizing that too. I mean,
look how much like the carnival cruise line just crashed recently because it's
terrible. Who would want to do this? I hate it.
I'm ready to go back to work guys. I can't, I can't do this anymore. In fact,
I don't even think I'm going to last through today, guys. I think,
I think I'm going to go back to the office right now.
Thanks for watching that video.
Want to be happy? Unlike me, you can go watch wills, coders,
new series on happiness. He just uploaded it. The secret to happier.
He's a good friend of mine and he put an insane amount of work into this here.
Go check them out. Lincoln subscription by.